[Music]
hey what's up we are streaming um we
happy few The Early Access I'm here with
Jean Luke I'm Jake um yeah uh so I say
we just get started hopefully everyone
can hear us we had some technical
difficulties before we
started but uh let's jump in so are you
familiar with this game at all uh I saw
it two years ago at PAX East and they
had this really really tiny booth in a
corner of like the Indie the Indie Mega
booth area and I was like oh that game
looks cute and uh I'm familiar with um
their previous game uh oh God what's it
called is the game where you're the
shadow
lady it was a launch game for the PS4 oh
wait okay remember talk about that right
I'm like called though and that game was
cool it was uh flawed but like I liked
the idea behind it I'm like oh these
guys seem like they have a lot of
talent and then I saw it
again uh at PX seat this year and they
had a massive booth and I was like oh
[__] they got some money um and then uh
yeah then they were at E3 on the
Microsoft show for I'm like okay that
explains that they got that Microsoft
money yeah did did you know it was kind
of a at least from what we're playing
now it's kind of like a rogue like no I
had no idea I assumed this game was like
a very narrative
heavy Bioshock kind of thing yeah
um you know more like more narrative
driven I guess than mechanically driven
uh but it seems like this game's very
mechanic heavy so yeah so this is a mode
in the game which is the only one
they're showing in Early Access it's it
which is kind of like a rogue like I'm
not there's supposed to be three I think
story mode sort of things um but I'm not
entirely sure how if those are like Rog
likes too with just quests cuz in this
you have plenty of quests to do oh okay
um so here's just a few
um we getting audio yeah we're getting
audio they're getting audio okay that's
good contrast that's the game thank Youk
contrast yeah yeah so this is actually
like the second area so I'll pull up the
map right
now so this is the area you start out in
over here um and I've made it just I
just made it to this sort of new area um
basically you just find like improved
equipment um I don't know yeah looks
nice it does look nice yeah um so so
yeah so the thing they showed at E3 was
the whole like opening cut scene right
where like you're the you're in this and
you will you will do
that but then has there been any like
cut scene story stuff like that since or
has it all just kind of been this
wandering around open World stuff it's
been wandering around there is like sort
of a main objective like Escape so reach
St George home um okay it's like main
encounters I guess but as you can see
the story bar so you've got Story main
encounters secondary encounters the
story one's locked off or there's
nothing there maybe not locked off there
A lot of like talking to
people uh I mean you're not Harry you
don't even look like him Mom Dad I've
come home I mean it's talking to a lot
of crazy people okay a lot of crazy
people but you're pretty crazy too it's
not my fault I'm being controlled by
someone I've never even met is that your
guy talking yeah I like that one CU it
makes me think that he's talking about
me controlling him like help I'm in a
video game we mad so these people have
the plague so I should probably stay
away from them to be honest can you get
that you can get the plague I died from
the plague oh on another playthrough and
not only did I die from the plague but I
died of food poisoning starvation and
thirst all at the same time well that's
a way to go so I I ate some bad food I
got food poisoning really bad and then I
just puked over and over again look at
this oh trap
um hot cassine was added your Journal
okay all right dig we can dig have you
have to find the shovel duct tape sweet
don't have enough of that oh
yeah um what is being guarded here uh
maybe up here h
oh what's
uh say yeah what's the little air eye
icon that is that they see you and that
that's how much health they
have so is that kind of how you tell
whether these people are hostile as
opposed to like the other people we met
who are just kind of not necessarily um
it just shows how much health they have
usually if a guy's guy's full health it
won't show anything cuz like you'll see
people wandering the streets oo this guy
had a lot
wow he had some inventory full damn okay
you want to get that key probably I know
but my inventory is
full so you can also expand your
inventory by picking up like inventory
expansion kits unfortunately for some
reason this playthrough I just have not
been able to find any but I can eat
we'll eat some nope I don't eat a rotten
mushroom um what can I eat do I have
anything to eat oh I do here we go
uh so this game just came out on Early
Access this morning right this morning
yeah uh do you know how much uh actually
I don't
know I should stop eating my stuff and
throw away all my and uh it's in Early
Access do you know like how much of the
game is complete at this point so I not
including like the story Mission head
knocker I don't need that not including
like the story missions I believe about
50% is done pocket expansion kit see
that's not what I want but I kind of do
need that all right we'll throw away a
screw I should have does it feel more
heavily um future complete though like I
think some Early Access games have a
problem where you're like oh this is
like a cool concept but there's not much
there and then some feel like this is
actually mostly done like you guys are
just kind of more um tweaking it I
think I um I don't know I think it's far
from done I think a lot of their like
main ideas already there okay and I have
the key I should be able to open this I
feel like um I I'm sure they'll add more
features but I think like kind of the
style and everything they're going for
it's kind of done um
but doing you wake back
up punch him so if you punch people
instead of like bashing with weapons
then they will uh then they just get
knocked unconscious okay so I don't know
if this guy actually
um advantage to oh I actually need
knocking them out as opposed to
murdering them steal stew damn it my
inventory is full I should have
offloaded a lot of this crap before um
sorry what were you asking oh like is
there like a morality to wanting to kill
people or uh like just knock them out
not that I
found okay that doesn't work um not that
I found um it seems
like like you really don't seem to get
screwed over for killing people but then
again I mean that could be something
that they're going to add later so I
just crafted a lockpick to see what's
inside
here I can put my stuff in this chest I
don't know if I want to though do you
have a a chest you can go back to or um
I do so I'll go back to my shelter oh
you have a shelter yeah so as at least
as far as I can tell each new area you
go to um there's a shelter actually
there may not be one in Joy toown um
which is kind of like the main town
where all
the that's all right just cans I killed
everyone in there so they're not know
don't worry about it um so each area
usually has a safe house that you can
that you can store your stuff in you can
rest you can do all that kind of stuff
this one though in particular is pretty
cool because the first one you start in
doesn't really have any like workbenches
or chemical stations this one has both
um and what that does is allows you to
craft more stuff when we get there I can
see if there's anything cool I can
craft um but yeah I
think there's a lot of there's there's a
lot of inventory management in this game
and I think that is probably
my biggest complaint I guess maybe not
even a complaint like it just
it it it it can be a pain like as you
just saw like it's like all right now I
got to check back um either you're into
Inventory management or you hate it it's
kind of a um very black and white yeah
um and then like another thing too like
there's a lot of events and stuff in the
world but this thing up here doesn't
Mark anything like the compass it
occasionally things will pop so you
actually have to explore and find stuff
well the thing is like even if you've
already found stuff you still have to
constantly check your map which is kind
of a pain and like part of it like I've
checked my map way more than I normally
would but part of is because I'm talking
and I'm not paying attention see I I
would be okay with I like games that are
that don't necessarily have a waypoint
and that are more about
um say like learning the layout of the
area so you know if someone's like oh
there's a quest by like I don't know
like a windmill and then by playing the
game you learn like oh I know where the
windmill is but this seems more like n
you just kind of pull the map up
constantly which like eh yeah I mean I
don't know I imagine that's something
they're going to they're going to add
later cuz I a feeling a lot of people
are going to think the same thing like
I'm just checking my map too much it'd
be so great if once you found a spot it
just stayed on that compass and you
could just that would be yeah that seems
like the way to go onion
um getting kind of tired too I guess
I'll put that in that a lot of I feel
like and like a lot of this stuff in
here I should probably just toss out but
I don't want to grab all that and
SEC Chuck it out the
door
um um gobu wants to know if you can
break down items you don't
need as far as I can tell no which
is I think kind of a problem maybe maybe
you can do it at a workbench though
yeah if it was like a crafting system
you think it would the opposite of like
oh break this down into metal bits
there's there's some things like I just
have a heck of a time trying to find but
I can find things that like have already
been crafted I guess with those mhm so
it seems kind of strange I'm going to
take a nice long
nap um now I down to
sleep and then like with this game you
need to watch your hunger your thirst um
make sure to sleep all that kind of
stuff although water is so plentiful in
this game like I it almost seems weird
that that's the thing you need to worry
about like it's just kind of more of
annoyance then it I I think it's more of
an annoyance um I hope that's another
thing too I hope like you can kind of
customize these sort of Rog likee
experiences
cuz like it would be cool to just turn
off all that stuff for like a
playthrough just to kind of like explore
check out different things sure or or
maybe go the other way and make it even
harder or that too
yeah um because I mean I usually tend to
like that survival stuff but like while
you're trying to figure out this game I
feel like it would be nice to turn that
stuff off sure um because like I don't
know Fallout I always loved like Fallout
New Vegas I'd always play with survival
mode cuz that was the was fun I'm
tempted to try four Fallout 4 with the
survival stuff since they added that
yeah I've thought about it but I don't
know that's a Time sync it really is um
okay should we see what's on Death
Mountain
yeah go wrong I don't want to break my
shovel though so I'm going to switch my
weapon if I have a yeah I got a stick
we're going to go meet the gorons we're
going to find the bigon
sword
what fight King Dongo okay I have to
drop
something oh I'll eat that's what I'll
do I need to
eat eat an onion
yeah did you uh did you play sir you're
being hunted I did not I heard this game
is very similar to it though yeah um I
actually didn't really like that game um
like that game's a cool idea but I
thought
mechanically it
um like just didn't feel very good to me
you know yeah um I mean feels pretty
good this seems better this seems like a
better version and I'm not trying to
like you know I'm not trying to hate too
hard on that other game but just like I
don't know it didn't feel it didn't feel
that good to me
um which uh kind of ruined the
experience a lot I don't think I can go
through here right now oh okay I need to
find come back tonight with offerings
okay so if you find a yam come back at
night they'll let you in a holy yam
though a holy yam what's the okay I
don't know the difference actually
though what I could do I could get to a
new area I think if I want to
backtrack um let's raid some houses
though okay this doesn't have any traps
on I'm going to walk through that one
just walk right through that yeah so
these don't do anything other than just
make loud noises um and just alert
people but there are like act like I
opened a chest one time and it exploded
in my face oh no
um so there are traps I don't have a is
there a way you could disarm you can you
need a tool okay needs clever trap tool
I wonder if I can craft that right now
so I can try it
out clever trap tool um so I need to do
it at a mechanical station I could just
run through though
and I might be able to jump this
probably not though oh I
did
exide
pills
so a crap well no one's in here rotten
car
there's we got a
recipe phyto
steroid um you can also do lots of drugs
in this game well maybe not lots of
drugs but I got a I got a thing um to
make hallucinogenics so that's what I
really want to try
see what that's like I wonder what if
there's a mechanical advantage to being
on
drugs um actually yes there is okay
there is fantastic I don't know if I
have any I probably shouldn't pop any
Joy pills right now anyway oh so I have
one Joy pill what that does is it makes
you happy and the reason why you want to
be happy is because you fit in with um
the people enjoy town because if you're
not happy like as as I think people have
seen in the trailer like if you're a
downer that's when they try to get you
okay so
sort of like a disguise almost yeah it
is it is a disguise near the end I can
near the end of the stream I can pop it
if we're not in that like a
and people say a lot of the same things
too call I'll tell you a I'm stay away
from you oh that guy got mad cool all
right see I'm afraid that so just that
just happened like sometimes you talk to
people and they're just like I want to
fight you now
maybe like this doesn't happen that
often I think he's okay see I don't want
to search him either cuz last time I
searched the guy with the plague I got
the plague yeah it's probably for the
best
um that was interesting
though see what quest we have
here come back at
night maybe at night we can do that
rescue the
chef
another thing it'd be nice if you could
uh like Mark Quest I mean this just goes
back to your mini map but I wish you
could just like Mark quests and then it
would pop up on the compass
yeah the altar of the yams that's where
we just were okay yeah over here need to
get a for so yeah as far as I can tell
the main objective of this sort of mode
is just to keep getting through
different areas of this town until you
get to joytown and then escape from joy
toown joy the end the end game I think
so I mean I haven't gotten past that
this is probably the way to get
there
quarantine maybe not actually this looks
like a yeah there like a crazy plague
area quarantine opens in one
day I wonder if it'll open if I come
back
tomorrow highly toxic I was going to
make a
um a halflife 2 joke about ravenol but
that place is actually called raven
Raven's home so yeah they made it for
me uh more
traps I don't even care I'll knock them
all
down is he going to fight you I don't
know got a little standoff
here all right back away see you all
right let's playing the heic I know but
he's not doing
anything I'm wondering if I like go back
in there nope fists are up it means oh
they automatically go up they
automatically go up yeah oh that's
usually a good indicator if someone
wants to fight
you so then this here too this is an
apple tree
but apples are for the citizens of
Wellington only so I think if I try to
get in there these guys are going to get
pissed those officers are gonna
and those are creepy yeah he doesn't
yeah I'm really you just like looked at
him all right whatever he's
gone but where's KY when you need him eh
so
tired um tired I know is there any
questions
any let's see anything people want to
see um otherwise I'll just keep kind of
exploring and looting um I can actually
go
back try to cross so I can try to cross
this bridge over
here sure I might be able to um because
I think I
needed I think I needed a power cell
which I got um took a lot of work I
should probably rest up
though back off
bananas yes bananas and
porcupines but if you have any questions
or if there's anything you want me to
try out do let me know as long as I
don't die CU then I have to start over
um yes we are playing this on PC
somebody asked that I don't know when
they asked that
um this is going to be available though
on Xbox is it right also available right
now on Xbox I'm not entirely sure I
think it is I think that was like the
thing with this is that you could that
early access was on Xbox was at the same
time as yeah PC but I could be oh man
killed you people I thought oh no I just
knocked them out must be get for not
murdering I
know oh dude it's got to be ay B around
here they don't have the plague anymore
last time they had the
plague
I like I've always locked you actually
yeah see I already searched them knocked
them out
already why won't you go away okay I'll
go
away all right so this is this is the
area you start out in it looks very
similar to the last area um that's what
I'm hoping I can get to oh look at that
that area looks nice so that is like the
the joy town or whatever but being in
there is pretty dangerous cuz you always
have to be like you always have to look
happy um you can't just like walk into
houses like there's alarm that you have
to disarm and like if they're not just
like strings with cans on them just like
in real life yeah just like in real
life um but let's see if I can actually
get through
there
um go wants to try out some crafting if
we have the materials for it
sure um I mean I can so I can craft
right in here oh okay that's good so
basic lockpick dir bandage I don't know
why you'd want to make a dirty bandage
over a bandage as opposed to guess it's
not as much is it not as much yeah like
I really need
this but yeah so there's basic stuff
mechanical a lot of the mechanic stuff
you cannot make unless you have unless
you're at a workbench and same with this
stuff you can make healing bomb though
but I don't have any stuff to make
healing bomb should probably go to bed
soon though see if I
can it's a tail told by an idiot full of
Sound and Fury signifying nothing what
so the character has like a whole bunch
of random like epiphanies all the time
which are pretty great oh my God that is
awesome one he was like if you're happy
on drugs then are you really
happy oh that's like some
uh weird
like 1: a.m. wake
up drug trip
Epiphany all right power The Joy
detector
so I wonder if that stays
charged
stomach uh you know
what I'm not
joyful oh man is that like killing
you oh
[__] okay dude you died um I should have
taken my I should get a second win
though but I'm just going to get up and
get oh you have a second win
yeah uhoh maybe not I wonder where there
it's going to
[Music]
happen they seem kind of whatever about
it okay you're fine I guess know I'm
going to go through and Get Zapped again
can
I yeah that sound nope nope does not
like you
run you make it all right I need to
heal oh this is going great oh I died oh
damn all right are you dead
dead dead dead whoa so then that is so
that that Perma death is on so now I
have to start over fantastic um but
let's I'm going to turn Perma death off
and we're going oh good you can turn the
prologue off should we see the prologue
um the chat really wants to but I feel
like you've seen a lot of it from E3
it's yeah it's the same thing it's the
exact same thing
so oh man you want to see that you can
you can go to our YouTube channel we
have that up there yeah part of it
though actually the E3 one didn't have
the full thing oh
really um but yeah so as I just learned
I should have taken my joy pill before I
went through there I was hoping I could
get through and then take the joy pill
believe I'm still
alive more or less ow feels like I lost
an argument with a
train I can't go back all right so
medical
supp
bits so it's Mrs STS
oh are the um take the letters so the
quests are always the same no so they
are oh they are they're good good
they're you Pro you're probably going to
find the same quests quite often in this
um but like they're
not they're in different places
um sometimes you won't
get um the same one like I don't know
like you could play through a game and
not have a certain Quest that someone
else has but from what I've seen like in
order to get to New areas there are like
you have two options for Quest um one is
to steal
honey from a bee
nest or be beehive and then the other
one is see what we've got here why are
you stealing
honey I'm sure he'll be in this one and
you can it's just some douchebag like
he's like hey I really want honey man
yeah he's he's a jerk see if I can find
him okay but the world's different um I
mean it looks the same but is it
procedurally generated it is
procedurally
generated um but I think it looks pretty
good for procedurally generated it
doesn't feel
um like you know a cookie cutter
no at least just like the way it's put
together like maybe if you play like for
a lot you're like well like I'm familiar
with this building you know or you know
oh I've seen this treeh house
before so every playr I've done this guy
has been here with this Mission he's
going to want me to break into a doll
house and steal or break into a house
and steal a
doll here are the other agents this is
kroer Jack Carter gonville bromhead Joe
bander and Nigel Powers but we're
missing peachi pichy carahan he's been
kidnapped and you have to rescue him
those were all some very British
sounding names here everything you need
to
Res all right so he gave me a Jimmy bar
we can try to rescue pachy what's the
Jimmy bar uh you just pry boards off oh
it's a crowbar yeah okay oh oh like a
Jimmy got it yeah got it I've got
friends coming over for Te okay must
late um I wonder if it showed up it
probably didn't show up oh yeah it did
no it didn't
um yeah go she wants to know is this
Downer town or somewhere in between yeah
so like you have joy toown which is like
um yeah this is Downer town down town
this is Downer town as Downer Town gets
okay so maybe there'll be more but it
seems like you have Downer Town joy
toown and then maybe like a plague area
it kind of seemed like potentially wish
I didn't die we could have we could have
saw that so seen this guy before suppose
I should help
him yeah so he I don't want your Rod
Apple turn around come
on you wouldn't happen to have an exide
would you m I think I have one a purple
pill you wouldn't happen to have an
exide would you make I'm trying to give
you one a purple
pill I think I ate something
BR nope I don't have one I'll take your
shovel
though
he doesn't need it it's
fine you're not wanted
here yeah I I uh I dig the Aesthetics of
this game kind of like that
um uh like
postwar um kind of a environment this
seems like some sort of alternate
history yeah probably like I mean I
don't really know the back I had to
guess it was like you know postwar kind
of like Britain never really fully
recovered from it or something like that
um do you know anything about like the
setting I think it takes place in the
60s I know that
yeah um
here I've friends com over
for sometimes I wish I knew you well
then I could I a
weird almost like Doctor Who vibe off of
this really yeah I think it's like
specifically um it the accents was the
accents but also uh that machine that
Zapped you actually like looked a lot
like um the the the dolls and I think
it's just
because Doctor Who was around in the 60s
and I think um you know the inspiration
that show had and its designs also is uh
seen here so there's just kind of some
crossover yeah you're probably right all
right uh she saw me uhoh dang
well you're trying to take the big chest
take all of it mysterious chest what can
you do with the rubber
duck o oh wow the shovel does quite some
damage it sounded next my pill there we
sound really
painful all right now I'll go give that
NEX my pill to that
guy dang I can't believe I died I'm sure
I'm getting no a lot of crap for that
yeah yeah one person slider was saying
they get a Bioshock uh Dishonored feel I
definitely get the Dishonored Vibe like
aesthetically um something about the art
style reminds me of Dishonored yeah I
yeah I mean I I get the same it
definitely and I think a lot of people
were expecting it to kind of like be
something like that but it is very
different at least from here so I had a
glitch where after I talked to him I
couldn't talk to him again so I couldn't
give him the pill kind of seems like
that's
maybe I think that might be happening
Oh e and I'd rather not stay here and
watch him
puke no search in the crate never mind
yeah I don't really want to watch this
anymore okay we'll leave him be you feel
thirsty watching that guy PUK you feel
thirsty
now I don't know you crazy train says
don't hit people with their shovel you
want it for later yeah yeah that wasn't
intentional I mean it yeah but uh yeah I
guess that's kind of like the tradeoff
it's like hey the shovel is super good
at killing people but I don't even know
if I have anything else it'll also break
it yeah I don't have anything
else
um do you know if it's just melee or do
they have um like are they going to have
guns or any sort of projectile I have no
idea I mean you can throw rocks that's
projectile I assume those are more meant
for like distracting though no you can
peg people with rocks there's a guy
there's a quest that spawned for me one
time where a guy just stood on a tower
throwing rocks at people and it was like
kill him so I killed him and the town
got mad at me and they're like hey man
we like that guy we like not being able
to walk through our Gardens because this
jerk was just throwing rocks he added
character to the town and now he's
dead he needed to
die was very passive aggressive I know
so everyone's very passive
aggressive
um
see uh pentac kill lemon the main goal
of this game is to escape yeah
um so I haven't seen this before oh okay
yeah this is not
spawn what's that
say please stop dumping chemal chemicals
you'll kill the
fish like I probably tried to drink it
why can't I give you the next my pill I
have an X my pill did you try holding
it what did I not grab it yeah I've got
two next it says like hold to give
screaming know I feel awful you would
let me to have a purple on you would you
mate all right there we go for some
reason I had to talk to him a whole
bunch of medical supplies all around
here I think I must have stepped on an
infed needle would you help me clean it
all up
else
sure I think the doctor
E I think they' forgot
cure
every Joy look at you being a good
citizen pick up syring did I get
everything
bandage is that everything I think that
might be everything no maybe not FKS
probably starting to roll in now bottle
syringe
uh I mean you missing
that
huh
I see get some sleep Arthur you're going
to make stupid mistakes all right well I
need to go back and sleep
anyway come back
later uh wait a second I only have a
shovel so one of I I always see this guy
start oh you just punch
him so incapacitate the runner that's oh
he's going to get away oh no I can
really catch him he's too fast once he
starts going he's going why do you want
to beat on him oh I might catch them
yeah I don't know it just there's a
mission that tells you to beat the the
voices in your head tell you to kill
them so let's do
it empty strange a lovely bouquet sure
we'll take a lovely
bouquet power up the TV open the chest
in each each
house why won't you go away interesting
I haven't run across this area
either little town
thing
all right we'll go back
to go back to the the
house you like me to you a story I would
love to hear
one
to oh here's the dollhouse maybe I
should break in here and take the doll
quickly get
water all right we're goingon to break
in the house and take the
doll so I needed a Jimmy bar for that
okay otherwise you just couldn't get
them
open see they don't even really care if
I'm in here get off you okay I'll get
off you little
bits comes at
night wait what did he say the fog only
comes at night okay is that does that
actually mean something so or just him
talking nonsense all right inventory
full
crap a I messed
up um we're g to drop some of the junk I
picked up in the pond hey just drop
these empty needles in their house
that's fine I'll never need to come back
here again I don't care all right get
ready all right now they're all going to
get mad yep
sleep other
way so yeah like it would be really nice
if the your your shelter was just on the
the compass so I don't need to check it
like while I'm being chased yeah that
seems a little and since you don't
actually pause it like it's still real
yeah it's still real time so it's like
not oh yeah no that's I don't like
that
um but like randomly things will show up
they be like oh here's an empty house
you can check out and it's like okay
cool but what I need and like that'll
show up but like I feel like some of the
important stuff just
doesn't yeah like there are certain
things that should maybe always be on
there all right um usually this
sign
means you have a shelter and usually at
least in the first spot right outside
the shelter there's
water oh yeah so are there more
like is there can you take a more
stealth approach like is it possible to
yeah you can do this game without
actually like having to beat up everyone
yeah so you can you can pretty much just
ignore people if you want um you can
incapacitate people too okay I need to
eat something
jerky and strange meat by the way
everyone uh thanks for watching uh if
you want you can uh go ahead and uh give
us a follow or subscribe if you want to
see more stuff like this um we are
playing we happy few right now uh just
came out on Early Access uh so you can
go check this out for yourself if you
want um would you give it a recommend so
far for from what you
played uh hm I I would wait a little bit
just because it is pretty buggy um some
things
are missing and I
think a lot of people weren't expecting
it to be a rogue like at least what we
can play right now so if you don't like
Rog likes I don't count this game out
yeah but uh if you really don't like Rog
likes then you may not like this game uh
by the way this game is $30 on $30 okay
okay which um that's fair I have a
feeling this game will probably be more
once it's out of Early
Access um cuz it seems like there's
going to be a lot yeah that that's kind
of the thing Early Access I
always so this is that the B guy all
right um Early Access is always feels
like a gamble to me yeah I should have
gotten water now see here young I've
I've been earned enough times where I
get a game in Early Access and then when
it finally comes out it's not really
much better or you know improved a lot
and you're kind of like oh okay well
like it didn't really pan out yeah I I
have I have faith in this game just
because there's a lot of people are
really excited for this
there's I don't know I guess I guess
it's hard to say but I think this game
will be pretty good once it's done I
think people are really going to like it
if but I think it's definitely not for
everyone like if you just want like a if
you were hoping this would be like a
Bioshock Dishonored sort of experience
it's not um that that's madebe my
biggest issue with the game is more just
um like kind of I mean it you know it's
been known for a while but that
Microsoft uh press conference was sort
of like the big unveiling to like a
wider audience and I feel like just by
only showing that opening and then not
really talking much about the rest of
the game they kind of potentially let
people fill in the gaps for what they
thought this game was and I think some
people maybe got the wrong idea I I kind
of did um yeah well I mean even uh
before they were before they I guess had
a deal with Microsoft I don't know how
that works if it's a deal or not um we
actually we actually played a little bit
at E3 2014 15
15 um and like I don't know it it was a
lot like this but like I I don't think I
really thought about it being a rogue
like I just figured it was like kind of
open World um what does that say on the
wall lots of crazy things a bunch of
names look it's not you it's me so yeah
you can knock people out rotten carrot I
almost killed you for rotten carrot
sick hey man got to do what you got to
do um should I keep looking in here I
can play the
piano
[Music]
I don't believe we've had the
pleasure you hear the same lines over
and over again yeah
[Music]
that hopefully they'll record more it's
not my fault I'm being controlled by
someone I've never even
met I mean
just the nature of the game you're
eventually going to hear more butu
considering we're
uh I like the delivery of that one
that's good I haven't heard that
delivery see that would help if if it if
even if it's the same line if they just
just give a different Cadence this time
yeah rotten actually I'll take a really
really emphasize the word when you say
it I'll take a rotten potato so Rotten
Tomatoes you can make antiseptic with
yeah so that guy seems to not care where
that guy is
maybe uh tough linen tough linen is hard
to come
by sometimes I wish I knew you well I
need that I'll come back to it maybe you
don't
understand good no one saw
that should I incap incapacitate you and
check the campfire should I
not
so take
it it's easy you take the goats across
first okay
sure little bits pocket expansion
so it's really annoying how I haven't
found any backpack expansions so pocket
expansions just give you more like quick
access
stuff next my pill so take am I right in
hearing that there are multiple
characters you could eventually play as
so there there's supposed to be three I
think is what I've heard okay um do you
know if that actually like changes
the story at all or I think it changes
the story I don't know if it changes
this guy's crying maybe won't CU that
opening cut seem seem very specific to
this guy um yeah so I'm pretty sure it's
going to change the story in terms of
like gameplay and stuff I don't know if
it'll be any significant difference like
I don't know if like one character will
have a perk as opposed to another and
this guy doesn't have doesn't seem like
he has any perks
no but I mean he's the only character
available so maybe that is something
planned for later okay here's where he
he's the default and then everyone else
is yeah kind of here's where I need to
get be
honey
um come
on where your be suit got to get a
padded suit that's why I need tough
linen which is hard to come
by but if I really wanted to I could
just rush in there you just rush in and
and I'll survive maybe I might need full
health to survive that's how I usually
because I never can find enough tough
Lenin to make one and I get sick of this
area so it's just like quicker usually I
just run in there but the last one I did
in order to get to the area I had to
like rebuild a plumbing system or a pump
system and that was a lot easier because
I just had to beat up some dudes at uh
like beating up on some other thing um
like a pipe and then I made one with
some metal bits and sure enough I got to
the next
area so that's what I was hoping for in
this game but it looks like I have to do
the dumb be
thing man it's kind of a bummer it's not
my fault I'm being controlled by someone
I've never even
met see so where it's definitely an
issue I I have with some of these games
uh is where if you're going to be dying
and starting over a lot if you know
after like two or three times uh a quest
like that starts to get irritating that
that's kind of a problem
yeah
um maybe I can give this guy's neximide
pill now let's
see do you think you're gonna get this
game give it a
try I don't know
um I mean I like Rog likes
but I'm
also
I don't know I'm I'm not like
super into like kind of like repetitive
cookie
cutter stuff like like I like Rogue
likes that um have the sense of
uh um what's the word looking for like
you you feel like when you die you're
like oh okay I I learned something and
then I can go back and I've I've
improved um like uh Spelunky it's a good
example exle that um I love that game
this game seems a little more like oops
I died all right I got to start over but
like might not necessarily have like
learned anything from that run or I mean
I learned to take my joy pill before
youill but it I don't know it doesn't it
doesn't seem like it has quite the same
sense of um it doesn't it's a lot more
slower paced like you're not going to be
dying like every couple minutes and
started like it is yeah and that could
maybe make it more frustrating where
it's like um man I got so close and then
you died and then you have to start all
the way over and like that can be really
demoralizing um and to be honest if you
do plan on getting this game in Early
Access I would recommend turning Perma
death off just because like even if like
I'm sure a lot of people are like oh I
want the challenge but uh last night I
was playing on my game at home and I
died because I got stuck in geometry and
then I starved to death oh so like I
couldn't do anything about it like I'd
quit out of the game and I'd still load
right into that same exact spot um I was
just endlessly falling like off a twoot
ledge oh man so it was I mean yeah that
sucked cuz it I I'd put in I don't know
probably not that much time probably
like well 3 four hours like that's it's
a good chunk to have to start over but
every time I've died I've moved through
this stuff a lot quicker so in that
sense you are kind of learning
things um I just hope there's more
variety CU if you do start this game
multiple times yeah
that seems like the the thing I'd really
want them to keep adding is like hey add
more Quest options add more dialogue
just like things to keep it interesting
each time you start over yeah and I'm
sick
of I'm sick of uh the stupid B1 every
time it's the
B1 how have I not found any backpack
expansion things that kind of really
bugs me
I wonder if they're going to get mad if
I fall down here I don't recall inviting
you I'm trying to get
out this is not good call
aui Castle and it's not your get out of
here all right I pissed off the town I
should
leave
okay so I can at least turn in that
Quest getting
light climb there we
go give ugly doll brilliant you we could
count on you Alfie hey everybody Peach
is back but look char cro has been
wounded he needs a first aid kit can you
get one I knew you could here's the top
secret blueprint for making one and you
can find the ingredients on this
map
okay I might be able to make one as is
without checking the map so I need one
bandage yeah I can make one without
do no room in my inventory son of
a
okay um so I see you got these unlocks
how do you how do you unlock so that is
a backpack expansion which I haven't
found any which oh wait I have one right
here this must be one I just started
with so there you go see look okay cool
cool but you those you just have to find
you have to find them and like some
games I'll find all of them in like a
couple minutes and like the last game
that I died on I hadn't I found like two
maybe and I hadn't found any other ones
okay um okay first aid kit I hate
wasting a first aid kid on your stupid
ass
doll well nothing lasts forever does it
go and get a first aid I all right there
you go okay here's the mission we've all
been training for you have to find the
secret invisible house and bring back
the ephemeral linen now listen carefully
you can only secret invisible house at
night and only when you're very very
happy
it's somewhere around here once you've
got the ephemeral linen we'll be able to
construct our secretest Weapon It's
called a suit of blending the
pachy we can use it to sneak into Dr B's
secret lir and stop his evil plan for
good all right Alie don't come back
without the ephemeral
linen all right so I have a joy pill all
right do you need that Joy pill to get
in order to see this house apparently Oh
weird and I can only see it at
night so wait is there like actual weird
is actual house I don't know yeah is
this like 100% drug induced or is there
like some actual weird magic going on
here I don't know I've never found this
house before this is as far as I usually
get in this Mission cuz really I want to
see what this house is like so one time
I was playing though and I was walking
through an area and like uh I think his
name is Harry or Henry was like I should
come back here at night because I think
there something might appear and I lost
where that was so and then I died so
like can you say custom way points on
the map no a see that would help then
because you could just say like you can
make a point and be like I need to go
back here cuz I that's another thing
that I hope they eventually are able to
add I think that would be
good um yeah I mean a lot of it a lot of
my problems just come from navigation
like mhm navigation should just be a
little bit simpler
off you bring out your dead bring out
your dead have you seen Monty Python in
the Holy Grail I have seen Monty Python
oh
yes um I'm Not Dead
Yet search Miss Marley's body I think we
watched that movie much easier after a
little that was like the go-to movie we
would watch in high school whenever
there's like we don't want to do
anything in math class or you know
something to do teachers I probably
watch that movie like 10 times in high
school movie so many times it's so good
yeah it's still it's still
great all right where's Marley's
body Nigel pickles oh man I really do
like the names so for I don't know if
they're like user if they're randomly
generated or not but they're all really
good I think they're randomly generated
but I could be wrong they Pi a good to
go to bed good selection after I dig
this up
oh we're going to have a chest here last
time I found one of these chests there
was so much good yeah look at that
chlorine antiseptic gas mask taking all
of it yeah I can make yeah that's that's
what I need all right what's the uh
what's the gas mask for um so I think it
actually you can wear it like in plague
areas and you should be okay cool um but
there's never been an opportunity where
I should like I've seen signs that are
like wear your gas masks at night but I
never do and I seem to be
okay hopefully they don't pass out so
does like the plague come out at night I
mean I've been out really late in this
game and I've never had that issue it
could just be certain
areas touching her toes or something do
not open going
in
oh see look it's 3:00 a.m. the PO man's
dinner and I didn't get yeah there was
no like plague or
anything but I don't know I feel like
just having a gas mask would be sure
yeah beneficial seems
useful all right let's see if I have
enough food to
survive another
day see I wish food was as easy to come
by as water that would be
nice it's a little weird they have like
an animation for you eating it but
you're in the inventory when you do it
so you don't you don't see it anyway I
can set it before I can equip it and
just okay that makes sense all right I'm
going to eat a Rotten Tomato good
luck oh not sick cool Rotten Tomato
seems like a really
bad like just eating a tomato I I don't
like tomato so just eating a regular
tomato would seem bad but like a Rotten
Tomato yeah so
mushy yeah no thank you not good but I
mean look at this we we get don't have
many options
yeah um yeah I guess I'm I'm really
interested in like what the about like
the The Narrative the state of the world
like why is everything like this um yeah
how did it get this way um have you seen
any of that stuff other than the intro
not really I'm sure like sweet maybe you
don't understand I'm sure there's hints
and stuff around around this game that
like this seems like a game that would
have the Bioshock um like notes on the
ground like oh oh and there is that
there is that so I found that um I'm
kind of just not picking a lot of them
up all right yeah I mean right now
that's not really that doesn't make for
an interesting stream let's look around
here again oh he's still trying to do
this oh jeez I'm just seeing no like I'm
not seeing anything could be maybe
something up here what do you get from
doing this Quest I don't know oh maybe
it's that bottle up there that's what
I'm thinking yeah that is what I'm
thinking no and then I can you can kind
of look a little
[Music]
bit I wish it there was like a number
like this is how many things you need to
pick
up oh wait I is that it
nope dang
it clean the medical waste from the
pond
man need to like stop the
pipe
yeah honestly I don't know we'll
uh we won't stick here too long though
see what else we can
do so I can Rush that beehive yeah grab
honey um so we can go to next area yeah
um do you find
that there's a lot of value in doing a
lot of side quests or like playing
through it multiple times now or is it
sort of like H like I don't actually
need to do these maybe I can just kind
of Mainline it a little bit more it's
weird sometimes sometimes yeah you
really want to make sure to do these
side quests other times I feel like
they're kind of not that important like
the one where I beat up that Runner like
I never get anything like
I and there's like no experience not
like I get experience for it like it's
just like hey
knock the [__] out of this Runner and
like
okay kind of feel bad for that poor
guy
um where was The
Beehive up here poison
Wast bees Crazy Train says uh save your
happy pills you will find a clue for the
magical house along the story when move
into new
areas okay so the so it's not in this
it's not in this sort of part of the
town then uh I guess so that's weird cuz
he says he says the house is
nearby and then yeah and then Crazy
Train was also saying kind of what we
know which is uh the main story isn't
really integrated into the game that
much yeah
um move out of my way woman I'm kind of
curious how that'll change the flow then
when more of the story is properly
integrated
um yeah um like there'll be more
cutcenes or like if the story is as
interesting as I hope it's going to
be I wonder if you can kind of uh like
turn off a lot of the survival stuff
Branch I I want that inventory full
never mind like if you want a more
narrative experience without all of the
survival sural stuff he wasn't there
again today that that would maybe get me
to play it um cuz the survival stuff I'm
honestly less interested in but I am
interested The Narrative so if there's a
way I can play this
game and just experience the story and
not have the um survival stuff kind of
like get in the way for me then I would
I'd probably do that
yeah this sewing kit I probably need
that uh Premium Pack uh this game is on
PC right now that is what we are playing
it on
actually
I
don't probably can't get rid of this
shovel there's no room in my inventory
all right we'll drop these
[Music]
bottles don't know
you
okay let's get to the
bees young I taxes yeah like I've
noticed like carrying cantens is like
not even that necessary just cuz I find
so many of those water yeah yeah but I
mean maybe it's different and like the
further you get like they probably come
in handy more oh yeah but at least early
on like I don't that can make
sense okay
all right let's hope I don't
die yeah I wonder if like this opening
area um kind of takes it easy on you a
little bit maybe with some of the
survival stuff and then the later areas
maybe get more intense over
time I think so all right we're just
going for it yeah we're just going for
it do it oh man you got you got to oh no
okay oh no they they did not like that
they are not
ooh dude you are one hit
away we're good we're
good yeah we're good oh my gosh that was
close yeah that scared me I don't know
why they were out
there they did not like you touching
that be hiive okay what do we got
here o
y got some healing bomb and can probably
craft some
more hopefully that freed up some
inventory space the crazy train is
saying that um if you throw stuff on the
ground it just stays there so uh if uh
you just like throw stuff at your house
and you can just kind of let it
accumulate okay um that's actually good
to know CU that safe doesn't have a lot
of space in it that's that's always um
something in a game I'm I think about
but I'm worried to try because some
games do do that and other games yeah
will like kind of do it but then
eventually disappears so you're like oh
no it's cool like I can throw all this
stuff on the ground and then you go back
later and it's all gone you're like no I
remember I think it was like Oblivion
like things would stay you throw on the
ground and then your game would be
running so like oh I got to clear the
cash and then it would just like all
that stuff would be gone like oh yeah
all right Oblivion in Skyrim with finy
with with that where some most of the
time it would stay but then for whatever
reason sometimes it it would just decide
no this isn't going to stay anymore and
you're like
no all right it's been going to get some
get a good night's sleep we're going to
drink up eat up and then we are going
to travel to the new area also
apparently your uh your stash is shared
between the houses in the area I didn't
know that yeah that is that's pretty
that's really cool that's that's good uh
do I even have anything to eat
I've got a bunch of crap but here's what
I can do so I've got a whole bunch of
rotten food which I probably shouldn't
eat probably not I have no maybe I don't
even have an exide pill oh yeah I do
I've got two okay so I can eat all this
crap so just eat it and then take the
pill and you're good yeah
let's is there an animation a vomiting
animation yeah but we're not going to
see it what if I what if I want to see
it I don't want to see it I've seen it
enough so that's what killed me I got
sick and everything I'd eat I'd just
puke back up and drink so
like I yeah I was like trying to get
from my house to the water fountain and
died um I forgot which one it is I think
it's it's this one I think this is the
one with the
bees and kind of a crappy thing about
starting about the B1 is that so like
the one I had last time you you saw me
go through that sort of tunnel thing
right yeah so the one about that one is
like once you open that it doesn't seem
to ever close like it seems like you can
keep doing it but with this guy you have
to bring him you have to bring him honey
every time you want to come through here
oh no this is the wrong one though
that's not where I want to be so that
that seems kind of annoying like I don't
know so if that's the case if it's that
annoying compared to the other Quest I
would honestly if you can like just
restart until you get the one exactly I
would just kind of like keep restarting
the game which so the intention though
is that you've crafted the padded suit
um which means the bees won't harm you
at least if they do it's like not a lot
I actually have never gotten that suit
because I can never find enough tough
lenen but yeah still then it's like you
have to a get the tough linen which
there's a pain in the butt so it's like
kind of random if if this wasn't a
stream I probably just would have kept
restarting until I got one where I have
to fix the valve because that is way
easier yeah and I mean even if you have
the pad Lin you still have to go get the
um the honey every time and give it to
the guy that still takes
time um
but I don't once I get through here like
I probably won't need to go back anyway
uh oh crazy train who apparently is just
dropping all the knowledge on this game
oh I don't want to drink it he says uh
you don't have to bring him honey if you
just knock him out the gate stays open
so okay show me how to knock him out
though I have I was trying to figure
that out all right Crazy Train tell
teach
us so like he's over here can
I you like throw a rock at
him oh oh yeah do it no why did you not
jump all right I want to this guy has
had it coming though I he needs to be
knocked not even knocked out I'm going
to freaking kill
him yeah surprise
yeah oh that's great
this feels so good he's probably just
knocked out though he's knocked out but
I'm going to throw him over the bridge
well you can pick up a branch and then
just probably beat on him
right basic lock
pick do
that that's super good to know look how
much honey this guy's storing what
a what an
[__]
I'll take all that honey
yeah mechanical Parts shredded raincoat
mechanical
Parts oh this is
great
okay I'm throwing them over the
bridge good
riddens
oh oh so close oh oh dud oh
my this is this is
dangerous I don't want him to wake up
though yeah I feel thirsty
okay so like last time I searched this
guy I got the
plague okay so we got the new area so
first thing I try to do when I get to
the new area is just am immediately try
to find that
shelter seems like the a good person
thing yeah um I guess it's not as bad
since I just Chuck that guy off the
bridge um and then another thing too
when you get to the next area you can
find a power cell usually um which are
really tough to come by I don't know
maybe maybe the chat knows how to find
them better so actually over here is
where I can probably find this
thing of course I don't have an nexomite
pill I don't think I do at least cuz if
I don't have an xine pill I can't I do
sweet
okay nothing to do with you
sleep wouldn't for I wouldn't
for
remember when uh like first person melee
combat was such a novel
concept there's like this time where
like I was like when R came out um which
I love that game that game is so good
that game is awesome but I remember when
it came out everyone's like dude like
this game do first person melee and it's
great at least like cuz no one knew how
to do that and like now I feel it's
pretty standard yeah I feel ter so this
guy I guess swallowed a ton of like
power juice or whatever it's called
thanks it and I think
I so this is how you get your first yeah
lot lot of vom vomiting in this game
yeah man vomiting is uh it's quite fun
apparently B so now we can now I can try
to cross that bridge again if we want to
but I'm going to try to find a shelter
first
so maybe what I'll do is I'll try to
find the shelter that's where I came
from I'll try to find the shelter I'll
go back into joy town and then probably
end it there yeah I want to see joy town
um yeah CU I think that'd be a cool
thing to show since I died like a [__]
last time yeah this area seems not that
different than the other one it's kind
of a bummer um there's different
encounters though so like if you know
yeah there's lots of different
encounters which helps but yeah it is
pretty syy visually not that different
which is kind of a shame but
um I think it's kind of supposed to be
though cuz it's still like you're not
like it's not a full new area
yeah Rob's going to want his computer
back soon
too
water yeah probably probably needs to do
some work yeah so look for a neon sign
usually the neon sign is an indication
that let's check the
map oh there's that apple tree
again so like this took me a long time
the first time and this time what 40
minutes maybe when we got here yeah so
you you are like learning things okay
yeah but like I said I'd still turn off
Perma death because if you get stuck in
Geometry yeah until you know it's it's
uh the game all the bugs are worked
out yeah I mean I guess I'm not sure how
the save system really works in this
game um but it saved like me stuck in
geometry and I couldn't load anything
else too so it just kind of like all
right well that's a
wash nothing come on where's that
shelter
I
don't the Death Mountain thing
again you don't belong
here it's like rotten food I don't want
rotten
food
uh some people want to know what we
think of this game uh who are probably
just joining in uh yeah you seem pretty
pretty positive on it for the most part
uh yeah I really like it I it has
problems but like I said it's early
access I think the biggest problem for
me personally is the compass like
nothing shows up on it which I think is
a shame because I'm constantly checking
my my map um and then I think the other
problem is just glitches which is to be
expected Early Access that's kind of
comes with the territory on that where
the f is that
thing run house come
on
I
don't all right I still have no
idea all right maybe up here I
think yeah up in this area
yeah do they know maybe the chat knows
do they know if sprinting um makes you
like thirst quicker
and that's a good
point do some want to
fight a killer on the
loose oh got plag
yeah
oh no search stay back stay back yeah
and now I pissed you off cuz you got in
the way am I
oh that was always the worst in games
like this like
um you like Oblivion or those Elder
Scrolls games where you're like
attacking and then your ally comes in
you're like no get out of here I'm going
to hate you and then you hit them and
then you're like oh no and then you get
a glitch where they're stuck in
aggressive mode for the rest of the game
oh you you saw that thing about the the
guy in Fallout 4 right where his um
Preston Preston Garvey got stuck in
aggressive mode and he and he can't die
and
um so he just chases you forever because
he can't die um but he was doing a uh
Perma death run so he had this like
Unstoppable Terminator Preston Garvey
chasing him uh cuz he was glitched where
he was uh stuck aggressively forever
it's an amazing uh D it's an amazing
thing you should definitely like there
have been some articles about it in a
video uh it's it's uh it's really
awesome so I don't have any NEX mide
pills anymore um at least I don't see
any so that means prob starting to roll
in about now I can't eat oh wait honey
does this yeah that does that does
hunger all
right sleep I'm going to sleep I'm
thinking yeah let's let's see Joy toown
yeah I'm thinking we go to Joy toown um
and then I'll we'll probably wrap it up
put up there I think that's a good idea
I don't believe the pleasure where I got
to work on those ComiCon
videos I should eat
though
oh I guess I can equip things too
that'll uh somebody in the YouTube chat
is saying that uh you can try this game
on Xbox for an hour for free oh really
uh which if that's true that's pretty
awesome to be honest though it took me a
lot longer than an hour to like really
yeah a lot longer but like not enough
time you'll get the idea of it but you
probably
won't I don't know you probably won't be
able to decide if you like it or not
unless you're really into Rogue leges
and you've been you know you knew what
this game was UN like apparently a lot
of
people um I would definitely skip the
prologue if I only had an hour because
that's GNA take so I don't think you can
the first time start up though yeah so
starting be like 10 minutes I think yeah
I think it's going to force you to watch
it the first time but the prolog is
really good like it it it sets a good St
like stage for what this
game yeah I I guess not what it is cuz
it's not not really story yet but like
it it's cool like what could be there
like if the story stuff they add to this
game is more of that I'm like I'm
totally on
board I'm stoked I got that guy I wonder
if I like threw rocks at him through
there and killed him like if that's
another way to do it well I wonder if it
would just be locked out for good
oh I don't think rocks can get through
that little CR
but that's interesting yeah I wonder if
you could like screw yourself
yeah I have no idea
okay where am I going going down there I
should have gone with him yeah that
could be another potential I
mean uh games like this there's always
the problem of oh like a a quest bugged
out or something and if it's a quest
where you need to progress then like uh
oh
um I'm curious to learn more about this
character though through the narrative
because he seems like he's already
insane like he seems as crazy as
everyone else like know what he says
like he's not different but I mean I
guess you have your own Little Shelter
so you kind of are different but I don't
know it's interesting yeah I wonder if
they're going to play more on that yeah
like I sort of wonder if maybe like
everyone is always
insane even the people in joytown are
it's just because they're on I'm sure
they're the most insane yeah like
they're just on Joy so much
that okay I'm not going to be an idiot
all right you got your joy
pill all
right here's your damn power
cell I hope I have a joyful still
prise get all right time for some drugs
does it change the the visuals at all
yeah it looks you see a rainbow it looks
different filter happier filter I
guess that would cuz that would be and
then I like the uh swing my arms oh yeah
there's like a rainbow road
now
yeah I haven't been in Joy toown yet
this is kind of cool that would be super
cool if I mean I don't know how if this
is asking for too much but like when you
take the joy pill just it completely
looks different visually you know like
that'd be kind of interesting but I mean
that's why I'm curious to find that
house cuz it sounds like it is something
that is completely different like cuz
this all looks like everything looks
happy everything looks like you know uh
put together but like the second The Joy
pill wears off all of a sudden
everything's in ru it turns out like oh
no this all is in shambles you know yeah
see this stuff looks awesome like I'm
into this this is
very how long does the dry pill last see
that green thing counting down okay oh
not that long yep so
uh I got to find one soon that's kind of
a bummer cuz I I want to like expore
this whole environment
more so apparently though like they're
not at least from what I've heard I
don't think they're quick to jump on you
if you're not on your
joy but I I almost guarantee you there
is no um there's no like shelter in this
area yeah I could be wrong maybe someone
in the chat will be like there is a
shelter you there's a thing about a gas
mask um but I feel like in order for
this the way this game works like there
shouldn't be one here because it seems
like this is where all the cool stuff is
and like it should be hard to
okay so like my joy is just about worn
off yeah people don't seem to
mind but uh that could
change stay on the outskirts right now
see if I can at least chart this
map cu's shop
right
and then that little eye is sort of like
you're come
down I don't know how should I end this
should I just stroll into town and see
if I piss people off and if I piss
people off yeah see how long I can
last try and blend in play cool
you're not lost are
you are you KN yeah like the rainbow
Road's gone h i wonder I probably need
to be happy there
yeah like I want it where kind of like
in that opening cut scene where like you
see them splashing the puddles but like
oh now that you're not your joy realize
like they're stepping on like a dead
puppy or you know something like messed
up like that yeah I think that would be
kind of cool so oh no the the road is
there okay but it looks like the house
is don't look nearly as happy and
colorful yeah they don't I definitely
like the they change like just the see
if I
can
barter okay so you could probably buy a
joy why are you still selling strange
meat I don't have enough for any of this
this
crap okay so there's a guard right there
so I probably
shouldn't well he's probably selling
strange meat because that's just what
everyone has but because they have joy
pills they probably don't care yeah well
I'm happy that they aren't so quick to
jump on you like you can still kind of
explore yeah it seems okay like they
were a little like hey man I don't know
how I'll get back though without a joy
pill did you forget your
joy oh nope oh oh
oh you better Joy right now Cheer Up
cheer up now so like
why don't they just give you one cuz
like like it's like look guys I will
totally take your joy pill like you just
need to I don't have one like instead of
beating me to death maybe just like give
me one you know they're too far gone on
the
drugs just beat that person
up
bye
[Music]
should I try to get back through here
get killed you're going to
die you disarm the thing that's super
reverse polarity well so like it kills
everyone on
Joy oh that that would be super cool
dude see if it works oh a priority
device oh that'd be rad though all right
I'll probably
die oh crazy train was giv a bunch of
advice I wasn't
looking uh there's an a house on this
area I think uh there's one in every
area you don't need Joy pills by the way
all you need is the mask they wear in
the suit okay oh so you need a dry pill
initially but just to get in but if you
have the mask in suit you're fine why
are you trying to kill me that makes
sense okay well that's probably a good
place to stop yeah so that is the Early
Access Alpha for we happy Fe it's $30 on
Steam right now and I guess you can try
the first hour free on Xbox if you like
Rog likes um this is probably a good
game for you to check out unfortunately
it's not well or fortunately it's not
what kind of people were expecting but I
think it's definitely worth a try um and
if you enjoyed this make sure to like
And subscribe and we have a ton of not a
ton but we've got a good amount of
gameplay and features on yeah we happy F
and we're going to talk about on the
lobby too so make sure to check that out
at 2 pm
Pacific um anything
else no that about covers it all right
all right thanks
everyone